If you start out a side project aiming
at it needs to make money,
you will make decisions on a complete
different level.
I think the beauty of a side project is
that you are so playful and experimental
because you don't put the money
component on it.
You don't put a layer of money on top of
it.
So I started my blog as my personal
visual archive of things I find online
that interests me and inspire me.
It was completely meant just to be my
personal archive and then slowly but
surely I realized because I started
looking at my stats and I was like,
oh my God,
this is not so personal anymore.
And eventually I realized,
Oh my God,
this is a growing community.
This is people coming back every day.
And then with that,
all of a sudden you get companies that
come to you and asks you,
Hey,
can you put my product up here?
Hey can advertise.
And again,
this was not meant to be a business.
So when all of a sudden the aspect of
money comes at me,
I had to really do some thinking and
like,
do I want that?
It's just,
am I gonna hurt my credibility by
putting ads on here?
But then the interesting thing was when
I was approached by Jim coudal and he
told me the concept of the deck network,
it totally resonated with what I wanted
it to be.
Like for example,
the deck network,
um,
is a teeny tiny ed that is on the top
left side of my blog.
I'm,
that rotates a second rss feed that just
rotates in and out and it believes in
the concept of you can only have ads
that are really catered to your
audience.
So to creative audience.
So it's not noise,
but it's actually irrelevant.
So I realized,
Oh,
wait a second,
I could actually have advertising on my
site that is actually valuable to my
readers because he points out maybe
tools they would love to use.
There is a way that you can add value
with advertising if you have a site or
whatever it is that somebody wants to
give you money for an exchange for
eyeballs just makes sure that it adds
value to whoever is reading your site,
that it is something that you completely
stand behind.
I will never ever write about something
if I don't love it and unfortunately
there's too many sites that debt just
say,
well,
we have to bring the Bacon home so we
just got to take this advertising and I
think that's where you ruin it.
That's where you lose the trust of your
readers,
your audience,
and there is nothing that a value more
than the trust of the people that come
back to my site everyday.
Your credibility is all you have and I
think it doesn't have to do anything.
Whether you run a blog or not,
it's in your day to day like don't lose
your credibility.
Don't sell out.